le plus jeune des veaux est âgé d'une
semaine et bien grossir le troupeau
d'une cinquantaine de têtes achetées en
2022 un éleveur normand des bisons
d'Amérique du Nord désormais dans le
Berry une première en région Centre-Val
de Loire l'animal me fascine en lui-même
de par son histoire sa rusticité
la qualité du produit fini c'est devenu
une passion une grande envie un rêve
d'enfant et qui se réalise aujourd'hui
c'est réalisé bio et maraîchers Fabien
Riolon touche à la félicité dans son
exploitation de 350 hectares c'est
protégé robuste et rustique ont trouvé
leur terre d'abondance
il se nourrissent à l'herbe uniquement à
l'herbe ils sont à la pâture toute
l'année on complète avec du foin sec
pour l'hiver quand il y a moins de moins
d'herbe verte et puis un petit peu de
céréales c'est une petite friandise qui
permet de les apprivoiser les veaux se
nourrissent uniquement les maternelles
et ils commencent au bout de quelques
mois de vie à manger de l'herbe dans son
atelier de transformation désormais de
la viande de bison moins grasse et plus
fine que la viande de bœuf on fait du
rosbif nous avons aussi
des côtes de bison des entrecôtes
bifteck toutes les pièces de boucher
qu'on peut avoir et puis aussi des
saucisses merguez
puis un petit peu de transfo
tous les produits de la ferme sont
transformés pour être mieux valorisés
en plus de la viande on produit aussi
des légumes sur l'exploitation qu'on va
exclusivement sur les marchés à la ferme
et on transforme aussi donc ces légumes
avec la viande de bison pour faire des
plats cuisinés comme le bison
bourguignon le bison Stroganov les
terrines rillettes aussi et puis on fait
un petit peu de viande séchée un rouvre
des bois alias ninho Stone les bisons du
bérets ont trouvé leur Eldorado et leur
cornes d'abondance